forget this stuff Jay grab my nature
Master Bob's Burgers has a cast of
hilarious and talented actors writers
and comedians do you recognize any of
these voices from other media let's find
out I wanna learn how people are made oh
are you serious number one the man of
many of our favorite voices
I missed it again I'm sorry can we go
back H John Benjamin is primarily known
for voicing Bob in Bob's Burgers of
course Thanksgiving what if like I said
are you
that fits but also with Sterling Archer
and Archer oh yeah that is pretty
upsetting Carl in Family Guy and Ben and
Dr Katz aside from the few animated
shows we listed Benjamin has voiced
dozens of characters throughout his
career here's my stand
and we're ready to go number two also
known as Tina Belcher
oh God I never noticed how annoying you
are I can't even understand what you're
saying Dan Mintz is a well-known writer
comedian and actor known for his deadpan
delivery when he does stand-up comedy
one of his signature moves is to keep
his eyes fixed Straight Ahead never
looking at the camera or the audience
due to his immense stage fright it's
clear he was the right choice to voice
Tina naturally bringing out her
hilarious awkward charm I don't think
this will count as an official patch but
thank you surprisingly there's a lot of
improv in the voice Booth Lauren really
encourages improvising which we couldn't
do if we weren't all doing it together
number three everyone's favorite
Troublemaker Louise Belcher yeah
Kristen Schall is an actor writer and
comedian definitely known for Lending
her voice not only to Louise here Tina
it's a patch for keeping Mom and Dad
alive but also to Mabel from Gravity
Falls oh yes you can keep chewing on my
sweater
she does a ton of voice acting but
doesn't shy away from live action comedy
as well you might recognize her from 30
Rock oh and who's worse than us whites
right I mean look at slavery that was
bananas or what we do in the shadows we
sent Ravens we sent 500 Horizons number
four what would Bob's Burgers be without
jeans inappropriate jokes
Channel 6 News they'll finger anything
with a pulse Eugene Merman is a
russian-american actor comedian and
writer most notably known for playing
evgeny murminsky on delocated and of
course Jean Belcher in Bob's Burgers tip
me butt put them on in my bum bum he's
also a well-known stand-up comedian and
has guests starred on multiple podcasts
and radio shows I'm Gene the boy with
the golden voice and golden ding dong
number five one of our favorite moms in
all of TV history I I play Linda Belcher
John Roberts is an actor comedian and
writer who actually bases the voice of
Linda Belcher off of his own mother
Marge this track just makes me feel so
powerful I think I'm okay now Lauren
Bouchard the creator of the show saw
John's old YouTube videos where he
impersonates his mom and thought he
would be a great addition to the Bob's
Burgers cast I I'm perfectly happy
number six also known as 19 different
characters on Bob's Burgers we couldn't
possibly get into all these characters
but two of the most notable ones are
Teddy and Gretchen wow you seem nice and
you're there you want to go with me I'm
flattered gretching but I can't Larry
Murphy is an actor and comedian renowned
for his versatility he voiced every main
character in the show Assi McGee and has
voiced several characters in shows like
O'Grady home movies and world girl Bob's
Burgers definitely wasn't his first
animation Rodeo excuse me a second I'm
supposed to talk to him like they're
real and I manager gets on my face
number seven the voice of Mr frond
oh I'm not just gonna go away if you
ignore me David Herman is an actor and
comedian who played Michael Bolton in
office space and was a cast member on
Mad TV from 1995 to 1997. he's done tons
of voice over work not only on Bob's
Burgers but on shows like Futurama
Brickleberry and King of the Hill before
I go
um
could I have one last kiss number eight
known for the recurring character of
Zeke we're gonna watch it get blown up
boom
he also voiced the character of Kurt in
the episode two for Tina as well as
Zeke's grandmother in midday run he is
also accredited writer on Late Night
with Jimmy Fallon you're a great teacher
Kurt you're great for noticing number
nine the voice behind Mort the funeral
director and his mother why'd you get
run out of bog Harbor for selling human
flesh to the restaurant Andy Kindler is
most notably famous for his stand-up
comedy as well as the many TV shows he's
appeared on and voiced characters for he
was a regular guest on The Late Show
with David Letterman the character of
Andy on Everybody Loves Raymond and a
major contributor to The Daily Show it's
not easy number 10. the voice of Tammy
I'm Tammy Larson and these are the
breaking stories Jenny slate is an actor
comedian and author who started out in
New York City in The Improv Comedy scene
she has acted in and lent her voice to
several other shows
this is so exciting I never get to do
anything this important including Big
Mouth House of Lies and cruel show I
really liked voices and I liked
characters with unique voices number 11.
who was a fan of the Sarah Silverman
program back in the day I'm gonna rub it
on my belly to get my scent on it
Silverman is an actor comedian and
writer most notably known for her
satirical comedy style I can't believe I
don't have a game anymore I mean like
what am I gonna do all day she was the
host of the two-time emmy-nominated
series I love you America she voices
Ollie pesto and Michener and Bob's
Burgers I'm busy today I'm looking up
how every celebrity looks without makeup
number 12. obviously all these other
half Andy pesto spitting your hand and
then shake it makes sense that Laura
Silverman would voice act alongside her
sister Sarah as they've always performed
together throughout the years she is
best known for playing a version of
herself Sarah Silverman Jesus Is Magic
aside from Andy she's also voiced other
one-off characters throughout the show
when I went to Camp I said my name was
Dallas and I was from Houston number 13.
Louise's partner in crime regular-sized
Rudy kind of fit me in man this is the
coolest I've ever felt Brian Huskey is
an actor comedian and writer known for
his roles in programs like people of
Earth Veep and another period you just
take the shaft
and I'll work the wheel number 14 you
might remember him as Moody foodie well
well well the guy who couldn't remember
my order finds my address Patton Oswalt
was one of the many celebrity cameos on
Bob's Burgers he's a notorious stand-up
comedian writer and actor majorly known
for his role as Spence in the King of
Queens even lending his voice to shows
like Archer and Kim Possible it's most
impressive but we will take the
springing out of your stepping shoes
number 15 what can't this man do thanks
for giving me an opportunity to act in
your commercial I've been working on my
accents which would you prefer Jordan
peel is most famously known for comedic
work in shows like key and peel and mad
tv as well as bringing us films like get
out and nope which continued to expand
the cinemagraphic narratives and horror
genres in ways we've never seen before
he also guests starred in Bob's Burgers
as Horus and look what I got here who's
your favorite President and the sofa
Jester the sofa Jester that's me knowing
who voices all of these characters
definitely makes the show a lot more fun
to watch what do you think did you
recognize any of these famous performers
by their voices alone let us know in the
comments who your favorite character is